let me discuss a doctrine that is
causing a lot of problems in our church
but it is a fundamental Doctrine you
need to
understand is the doctrine of the Holy
Spirit have you ever heard of the word
anti anti-
trinitarianism it means uh an opposition
to the teaching of the Trinity and the
spirit of God but again before I get
into that let me pray Our Father in
Heaven as I la into this very very
important subject I ask you in the name
of Jesus Christ give me wisdom dear God
as I deal with the third member of the
godhead in Jesus name I pray
amen go to Genesis
1 in the beginning God created the
Heaven and the Earth verse two and the
Earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the dead
and the spirit of God moved upon the
face of the waters we see immediately
the first member of the godhead
mentioned in the Bible by name is the
spirit of God and the spirit of God
moved upon the face of the waters let's
go to Genesis chapter
6 Genesis
6 we read from verse
one when you find that amen and it came
to pass when men began to multiply on
the face of the Earth and daughters were
born unto them that the sons of God saw
the daughters of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which
they chose and the Lord said my spirit
shall not always strive with man here
again we have the mention of the spirit
of God so he's the first member of the
godhead mentioned Genesis 1:2 he's
mentioned again Genesis 6
verse3 now let us go to uh Matthew
28 Matthew
28 you read from Verse
18 of Matthew
28 when you found that say
amen and Jesus came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me in
heaven and in Earth go ye therefore and
teach All Nations baptizing them in the
name of the come on of the and of the
and of the yes Jesus said baptize in the
name of the father and of the son and of
the Holy Ghost so Jesus himself
acknowledges the presence of the holy
spirit let me say that again Jesus
Christ acknowled a knowledges the
existence of the spirit of God let us go
to
John go to Matthew chapter 3 I talked
about it this morning Matthew chapter
3 you read from verse
16 of Matthew
3 you have that and Jesus when he was
baptized went up straight away out of
the water and lowed the heaven were open
unto him and he saw the spirit of God
descending like a dove and lighting upon
him and L a voice from Heaven saying
this is my beloved Son in whom I am well
pleased I want you to observe something
where was
Jesus where was he in the
river what did he see coming down from
heaven the dove the holy spirit in the
form of a dove now the Holy Spirit can
take any form in Acts chapter 2 he took
the form of fire which sat on each
disciple go the spirit can take any form
he desires what I want you to see is we
have Jesus in the water and the spirit
in the form of love coming down so we
have two
entities are you with me some people say
the spirit is and Jesus are the same
person no we have two separate entities
one located in the water one coming down
the sky verse 17 says and low a voice
from Heaven saying unto him this is my
beloved Son in whom I am well pleased
now we have a third entity where is this
third person in heaven so we have
someone in heaven we have an entity
coming down and we have Jesus standing
in the river now the entity that came
down the holy spirit in the form of a
dove where did it a
light on the shoulder of Jesus now if
there were same thing Jesus cannot sit
on his own shoulder are you following me
are you following me Jesus cannot sit on
his own shoulder clearly we're dealing
with two different entities the son the
spirit and of course the voice from
above the voice of the Father the Bible
tells us there's father there's son and
there's Holy Ghost now let's go to John
14 John 14
read from verse
16 you have that and I will pray the
father and he shall give you another
comforter that he may abide with you
forever pause and I who's that will pray
the father did Jesus pray to himself no
he's praying to the father father so we
have two and he's asking the father to
send someone who's that the comforter
called the spirit of Truth here again we
have the father we have the son and we
have the Holy
Ghost are you with me and so we have
Jesus saying baptized in the name of the
Father the Son the Holy Ghost we have
Jesus coming out of the water the spirit
sits on his shoulder in the form of a
dove and and the father speaks from
above all right let's stay in John 14
let's read verse 26 of John
14 but the comforter read with
me which is the Holy Ghost whom the
father shall send in my name he shall
teach you all things and bring all
things to your remembrance whatsoever
have said unto you look at that verse
again and but when the but but a
comforter which is the Holy Ghost that's
one person whom the father shall send so
the father sends the Holy Spirit but in
the name of Jesus so we have three again
the Father the Son and the Holy Ghost is
that clear all
right let's go to Hebrews chapter 5
we'll read from verse one of Hebrews
5 have you found
it all right Hebrews 5:1 for every high
priest taken from them among men is
ordained for men in things pertaining to
God that he may do What offer both and
sacrifices for who can have compassion
on thee and on them that are out of the
way for that he himself is compassed
with in infirmities keep read and by
reason hereof he ought as for the people
so all for himself to offer for sins now
that's the high priest listen carefully
read verse
four and no man taketh this honor unto
himself but he that is called of God as
was Aaron let's read verse four again
read microscopically and no man taketh
this honor unto himself what does that
mean what does that mean what's the
honor that no man takes to
himself the position of high priest
whether on Earth or anywhere else no one
self selects himself for that
position but he that was called of of
God as was Aaron Now read verse 5 so
also mhm Christ glorified not himself to
be made a high priest but he that said
unto him what Thou Art my son today have
I begotten day what do I want you to see
someone chose Christ to be high
priest are you following me someone
anointed Jesus to be high priest of
course in the Heavenly century
those who argue that the Trinity is
really the same person expressing
himself differently will have to explain
how Christ could anoint himself as high
priest when we just read Christ did not
appoint himself to that position someone
else had to appoint him who appointed
him the father but who anointed him
let's go to John acts
10:38 looking at the Trinity and the
spirit in all one presentation two big
subjects but we just have the time we
have the book of Acts chapter 10 verse
38 and I hope you're
concentrating I don't want anyone to
deceive you regarding the Holy Spirit
and regarding the
Trinity how God anointed Jesus of
Nazareth with what the Holy Ghost and
with power who went about doing good and
what healing all that were oppressed of
the devil for God was with him now the
Bible tells us that Christ was
anointed the father anointed him but the
father did not anoint him personally
directly God uses agents let's see who
actually anointed Christ go to Luke
chapter
4 let's read Verse
18 Luke chapter 4 reading Verse
18 I forgot to ask my three regular
favors but I'm sure you know what they
are you have Luke 4 verse 18 let me pray
again father as I continue please grant
me extra wisdom and simple speech in
Jesus name I pray amen read Verse 18 of
Luke the spirit of the Lord God is upon
me go on because he come on hath
anointed me to do what praise the gospel
to the poor stop he hath anointed me but
in Acts 10:38 the Bible says how God
anointed Jesus of Nazareth with the Holy
Ghost and with power Acts says God Did
It Luke says the Holy Spirit did it it
is God that did it through the Holy
Spirit again we have God the spirit and
the son let me say it again based on
Hebrews 5 Jesus could not have anointed
himself to the position of high priest
someone else had to do it so the Trinity
must be made up of several people not
one person expresses himself in three
different ways as some people
say let's go to Exodus 29 I think it is
Exodus
29 and someone read for me verse 7 of
29 do we have that what does that
say then shallal thou do what take the
anointing oil and do
what whose head is
that whose head who takes the anointing
allil Moses pours it on whose head Aaron
so we have Moses anointing Aaron as high
priest Moses functioning in the position
of God Aaron the high priest represents
whom Christ that's symbol now the
reality is the father through the Holy
Spirit anointed Christ to be high priest
which is what he is now I'm saying again
the Trinity cannot be one person
expressing himself in three different
ways the Bible evidence is to clear the
Trinity uh refers to three separate
entities
okay let's go to the Book of Romans
Romans let's read verse
9 Romans verse
9 oh Romans chapter 8 sorry verse 9
thank you Romans chapter 8 verse
n are you there read with me but he not
in the flesh but in the spirit if so be
that the spirit of God dwell with you
keep reading now if any man have not
the he is none of read that verse
again we have two references for the
Holy
Spirit he's called the spirit of look at
the
verse he's called the spirit of and the
spirit of so we have Christ we have God
we have the Holy Spirit because he
represents both let me show you what I
mean by he represents both go back to
John
14:26 John
1426 are you there on read with me but
the which is the whom the father shall
send in my name he shall teach you all
things now in that verse who sends the
spirit
the father but in whose name the name of
Jesus so we have Spirit father Jesus
observe now the father sends the spirit
is that clear go to chapter 15 read the
same verse
26 you have John
15:26 read with me but when the
comforter is come whom I will send unto
you come on from the father wait a
minute
pause verse 26 of chapter 14 says the
father will send a spirit in the name of
Jesus verse 26 of chapter 15 says Jesus
will send the spirit from the father now
what does that tell you of the
relationship with the father and the son
to the holy
spirit either one of them can
come on think either one of them can
send him yes but I have to be sure you
see
that I'm not sure you've seen it look at
John
14:26 but the comforter it is the Holy
Ghost
whom the father shall send come on in my
name
so we have the father sending the spirit
in the name of Jesus in John 14:26 look
at John 15:26 but when the comforter is
come whom I will send unto you from the
father even the spirit of Truth which
proceeded from the father he shall
testify of
me now if you put 14:26 with 1526 what
is the relationship between the father
and the son and the spirit both the
father and the son can send the
spirit if that's clear say amen I want
to think I'm speaking in simple terms
having said that both the father and the
son can send the spirit go to John
Chapter
13 John
13 we'll read verse
16 you have that read it with me
verily verily I say unto you the servant
is not greater than his Lord come on
neither he that is sent greater than he
that sent him pause Take 5 Seconds to
think what do you see in that
verse name the two people in that
verse the
servant come on and the Lord what does
the verse tell you about their
relationship
equal where do you see
that who sends
whom and who is
greater
why because he's the one who sends then
the principle is the person who sends is
greater than the person
sent I'm not convinced everyone is
following me
are you not
following oh you're following okay I'm
encouraged on my right I need
encouragement from the left and the
sent verily verily I say unto you the
servant is not greater than his Lord
neither he that is sent greater than he
that sent him clearly the verse is
saying the person who sends has more
Authority than the person sent is that
clear
now recite John 17 John 3:16 for me well
no no let's say John
17:3 and this is life eternal that they
might Know Thee the only true God finish
the verse come on finish the
verse who sent
Jesus now go to John 14:28 keep it mind
the father sent Jesus now go to John
14:28
read with me what does that
say ye have heard that I said unto you I
go away and come again unto you if ye
loved me you would Rejoice because I
said
I keep
reading my father come on is greater
than I
why because the father sent him not
because the father is more
Divine are you following
me because the F the father has more
Authority the father sends the son the
father also sends the
spirit but the spirit does not send the
father nor does the Father the spirit
send Christ now let me say quickly when
Christ was on the Earth as a human being
yes the spirit sent him because the
spirit was sending a human
being but Christ in his divinity is not
sent by the spirit Christ as God sends
the spirit the father sends the spirit
but the father sent the son not
confusing you now based on all that
confusing talk give me the hierarchy of
power in
heaven the father come on the son and
the spirit
M
now that's how they are with respect to
Authority the Father the Son the holy
spirit with respect to Divinity they're
this equal are you with me they are
equally Divine fully God each one but
regarding Authority there this father
son Holy Spirit this image was part of
what God meant when he said let us make
man come on in our image give me the
power structure in the
Home Father come on uh-huh
yes but who's more
human Come on talk to me which one is
more of a human being they are fully
human H give me the power structure in
the local
church come on don't be hesitating your
pastor is sitting right there come
on the pastor mhm
Elders
yes but whom does Jesus love more you
know for whom did Jesus die
M which one of them needs forgiveness
more are you with
me father son Holy
Spirit now there's a a question in the
church among some the holy spirit is not
Divine like the father let's go to 1
Corinthians
2 1 Corinthians chapter
2 how are my little brothers doing
upfront how are you nice to see
you 1 Corinthians
2:9 are you there 1 Corinthians 2:9
but I hath not seen come
on now ear heard neither hath entered
into the heart of man the things which
God hath prepared for them that love him
now carefully but God hath revealed them
unto us how by his Spirit pause keep
reading now for the spirit searcheth
what all things keep reading yay the
Deep things of God now let me put this
in in Modern
English everything God knows read my
mind and tell me what I'm about to say
the Holy Spirit knows that tells you
immediately that the spirit is as Divine
as the father everything the father
knows and the father is omniscient the
Holy Spirit
knows but it is still the father has
higher authority not more
Divinity higher
Authority are you with me who's the
highest angel in heaven Gabriel and then
the Angels under him but they were all
created are you following me on on on on
the basis of how they were made is the
same Gabriel created the angel under him
created the angel under that angel
created down to the lowest Angel they're
all the same in respect to the fact they
were created but with respect to
Authority it is brother Gab
real let me show that to you in a
negative way go to Luke
11 and we'll come back to the Holy
Spirit Luke chapter 11 we're looking at
Authority not substance
Authority Luke 11 let from verse I think
it's
24 when the unclean spirit is gone out
of the man is that 23 or 24 24 when the
unclean spirit is gone out of the man
what does he do he walth through Dry
places seeking rest and finding none he
saith what I will return and my house
from when I came out keep
reading when he cometh he findeth it
swept and garnished
pause when someone is delivered of demon
possession that demon would love to come
back the demon wanders around and
decides let me see if my old home is
still available for occupation
Bible says he comes back he finds it
swept and empty the person didn't fill
up the space with the word of God with
prayer with missionary word Now read
verse
26 then goeth he and taketh to him what
seven other spirits come on more wicked
than himself
pause seven other Spirits more wicked
with more power to do wicked things now
where did these Wicked Angels come from
what were they before they were Wicked
Angels they were good
Angels they had different levels of
power when they left they left with the
same power but now they had more power
to do evil than other Angels what I'm
saying to you is this some of Satan's
demons have more power than
others because that's the way it was
when they were good angels in heaven are
you following me they took the structure
with them they did not lose their power
Ela white is very clear Satan lost his
position but he took all his power with
him I wanted you to see even among the
Angels We Have a
hierarchy hierarchy is part of God's
image we have the high priest am I right
then we have the
levite who could go into the holy Place
once a year the levite or the high
priest only the high priest but with
respect to he Humanity there were
this all right let's go back to the Holy
Spirit let's look at something God can
do let's go to Isaiah 45 let's read
verse
22 looking at the spirit and also the
Trinity Isaiah 45 reading verse
22 do you have that look unto me and be
saved all the ends of the Earth come on
for I am and there is now look at that
verse carefully what is meant by I am
God and there is no else none
else what does the verse say look unto
me and be
saved now then the verse ends there's
none like me what does that
mean
there's take a
guess there's no one else who
can
save look unto me and be saved all the
ends of the Earth for I am God there's
none else no one else can save let's
look at the same God read Verse
18 but thus said the Lord that did what
created the heavens God himself there
formed the Earth and made it he hath
established it he created it not in vain
he formed it to be inhabited I am the
lord and there is none else what does it
mean by there's none
else there's none else who can
create are you with me he didn't say yes
or
no I feel all alone in this
Pulpit Verse 18 I am God I alone can
create verse 2 two I am God I alone can
save go to chapter
46 Isaiah 46 let's read from verse
9 are you there remember the former
things of old keep reading I am
God there's none what I am God there's
none keep reading declaring the end from
the beginning and from ancient times the
things are not yet done stop what is God
saying by there's none else like me in
that
passage there's no one
else yes there's no one else who can
tell the end from the
beginning only God can tell the end from
the beginning Isaiah 469 and 10 only God
can create Isaiah 4518 only God can save
Isaiah
45:22 now let's start with save
we're trying to see if the holy spirit
is fully Divine go to John chapter 3
listen to
Jesus John chapter
3 let's read verse
8 you have
that the spirit bloweth where it listeth
and thou hearest the sound thereof but
can not tell whence it cometh or whether
it goeth so is everyone finish the verse
that is born of the spirit what do you
understand by born of the spirit give me
one word for
that starts with a
C then an
O
conversion the new birth justification
by faith Jesus says it is done through
the spirit
which means the spirit can do
what
s a save what did be read in Isaiah
45822 look unto me and be saved all the
ends of the Earth I am God there's none
like
me the spirit says Jesus is the one who
carries out the new birth that salvation
only a Divine being can carry out the
process of the new
birth that
Salvation let's look at
creation go to Psalm
105 Psalm
105 no not Psalm
105 Psalm 104 let's read 29 and 30 Psalm
104 29 and 30 not 105 104
this by the way Psalm 104 is entirely
dedicated to God working in nature
that's what lovely Psalm entirely
dedicated to the wonders of God in
nature and God's provision for his
creation all right read verse 29 for me
what does that
say thou hidest th their th thy face
their troubled thou takest away their
breath they and return to their Dust In
other words nature depends on God for
life read verse
30 thou sendest forth thy Spirit come on
they are created and thou renewest the
face of the Earth the spirit has the
capacity to
create are you with me so God Alone can
save Jesus said the spirit is the one
who saves God Alone can create the Bible
says th send this forth the spirit they
are created now let's look at tell the
end from the beginning go to 1 Peter
chapter 1
trying to show the spirit of God is as
fully Divine as
god let's read from verse
9 receiving the end of your faith even
the salvation of your souls of which
salvation the prophets have inquired and
searched diligently who prophesied of
the grace that should come unto you now
read 11 very carefully for me searching
what and what manner of time the spirit
of Christ which was in them when they
signified the sufferings of Christ and
the glory that should be revealed now
when the Old Testament prophets were
writing H What Spirit Led
them the spirit of Christ the holy
spirit Spirit of Christ he was leading
them now go to
Jude chapter 1 let's read from verse 14
Jude chapter 1 the only chapter it has
verse
14 go to the back of the Bible back of
the Bible all the way to the back final
Revelation and it is the book just
before
Revelation chapter 1 verse
14 have we got that read with me and
Enoch also the seven from Adam prophet
side of these saying behold the Lord
cometh with 10 thousands of his Saints
to execute what judgment upon all stop
let's look at that passage
carefully and Enoch also the what
seventh from Adam let's look at the
seven Adam Seth Enos kinan mahalalel
Jared
Enoch the Bible is saying Enoch preached
about the coming of Christ
even when Adam was
alive because Enoch and Adam lived
together quite a few years when Enoch
was preaching behold the Lord cometh
with 10,000 of his Saints to execute
judgment and all Adam was
alive that's way back now look at what
Enoch said behold the Lord cometh with
10, thousands of his Saints clearly that
is not the first coming of Christ
because when Christ came the first time
he did not come with 10,000s of his
Saints then where should we look
next second
coming but at the second coming he does
not execute
judgment when is Judgment
executed the third coming now then how
far back is Enoch speaking of the third
coming of Christ that's about six seven
thousand years ahead of his time how did
he know that he's a prophet 1 Peter 1:1
the spirit of Christ which was in him
I'm trying to get you to see the spirit
knows the End come on from the
beginning and that's a feature of God so
we've seen the spirit is involved in
Salvation the spirit is involved in
creation the spirit is involved in
prophetic interpret or prop prophetic
predictions the end from the beginning
those are things only God can do the
holy spirit is fully
Divine now let me show you how dangerous
it is to talk badly about the holy
spirit let me pray again father as I
continue give me more grace and simple
language in Jesus name I pray amen we're
looking at why it is dangerous to deny
the spirit or to say the spirit is less
than God Matthew 12 reading from verse
31 you have Matthew
12 reading from verse
31 read for me what does that say
wherefore I say unto you all manner of
sin and blasphemy shall be forgiven unto
men but the blasphemy against the Holy
Ghost shall not be forgiven unto men
stop you blaspheme the Holy
Ghost there's no
forgiveness and where there's no
forgiveness there is no possibility of
being
saved read verse
32 and whoever speaketh a word against
the son of God it shall be forgiven him
who is the Son of God Jesus keep reading
but whosoever speaketh against the Holy
Ghost it shall not be forgiven him
neither in this world neither in the
world to come let's look at 32 closely
we have two beings in that verse what
are they who are they Christ and the
Holy Spirit now the verse says you can
blaspheme Christ and be
forgiven you cannot bless the Holy Ghost
and be forgiven now if you go along with
those who say the Holy Ghost and Christ
are the same person we have a big
problem because the verse says you can
blashe one and be forgiven not the other
we have two separate beings again the
spirit of God and Christ are two
separate individuals you include the
father three distinct and separate
individuals all right let's go back to
Matthew to Romans 8 to see more
information as to why it is dangerous to
deny the spirit of
God ma uh not Matthew sorry Romans
8 Romans chapter
8 let's read verse
9 are you
there but he not in the flesh but in the
spirit if so be that the spirit of
God dwell in you now if any man have not
the spirit of Christ finish that verse
he's none of his now If you deny the
existence of the Holy
Spirit you don't have the Holy Spirit
and the Bible says anyone who does not
have the Holy Spirit does not belong to
God if any man have not the spirit of
Christ he's none of his those who argue
against the reality of the spirit being
an individual do not realize the Peril
they're placing their souls in the Bible
is clear without the spirit within you
you are not counted as a child of God
and consequently you can only expect
destruction tell me what you've heard me
say so far this afternoon tell me
anybody you must have remembered
something the spirit
what is sent by the father and the son
which
means which means
what say that
again he doesn't no he doesn't send the
father or the son so what does that tell
you
about
Authority the father and the son have
more Authority than the spirit this
relationship but with respect to
Divinity it's like this what else have
you heard
someone back there who is not sleeping
come on what have you
heard you must have heard something I'm
using a
mic you're not counted as a child of God
If you deny the spirit you are not
counted as a child of God okay true
somebody else what have you
heard the holy spirit is as Divine as
God the father and the son three fully
Divine
Almighty beings but different
responsibilities somebody
else who was that nice person who spoke
oh there you are yes all manner of sin
and blasphemy against men or against
Christ can be forgiven the blasphemy
against the Holy Ghost is not
forgiven so you better be careful what
you say about the Holy
Spirit some where where oh
yes oh yes yes yes he's involved in
creation salvation
and prophetic prediction qualities of a
Divine being mhm anything
else the Holy
Spirit let's go to John
16 no let's go to John 14 we look at
some Greek words
now John
14 we read from verse
16 have you found it I'll pray again
Holy Father as I continue please tell me
what to say to your beloved people in
Jesus name I pray amen and I will pray
the father and he shall give you another
comforter that he may abide with you
forever
now you see the word
another the Greek word there is
alos in the Greek there are two words
for another there's alos a a l oos and
there's heteros h e t e r o s now listen
to me carefully heteros means another of
a different
kind are you with me if I'm eating a
banana and I say give me another banana
what would you give me another banana
but if I say give me another fruit you
can give me an Apple are you following
me all right now I will send you the
pray of the father he shall give you
another com you see the word hetero in
heterosexual people attracted to members
of a opposite sex now the Greek word
alos means something of the same
kind Jesus says I will pray the father
and he shall give you another alos
comforter someone just like
me let's go to 1 John Chapter 2 take a
look at that 1 John Chapter 2 let's read
from verse one we're talking about the
Trinity and the Holy Spirit wrapped up
into
one 1 John Chapter 2 you'll read from
verse
one when you found it say
Amen reading my little children these
things WR I unto you that you sin not
and if any man sin what we have an
advocate with the father who's that
Jesus Christ the righteous stop we have
an Advocate who is The Advocate Jesus
now the Greek word means comforter are
you with me the Greek word translated
Advocate means comforter which is the
same word in John 14:16 he shall give
you another comforter so that Jesus is a
comforter 1 John 2 ver1 or verse two the
holy spirit is a comforter John 14:6 why
because both are fully Divine the Holy
Spirit represents Christ perfectly
he shall give you another comforter that
he may abide with you forever even the
spirit of Truth the spirit of Truth Now
recite John 14:6 for me you in that
chapter read
6 come on Jesus saith unto him I am the
way John 14:6 is wellknown verse I am
the way the truth and the life now I am
the way the truth and the life Jesus
says even the spirit of Truth so Jesus
is truth the holy spirit is truth go to
1 John chapter
5 1 John
5 let's read from verse six what does
that say this is he that came by water
and blood not
by even even Jesus Christ not by water
only but by water and blood now and it
is a spirit that beareth witness finish
the verse because the spirit is truth
but Jesus says I am
truth what Jesus
is the spirit is now go to Deuteronomy
chapter 32 Deuteronomy chapter 32 let's
read verse
four looking at the Trinity and the Holy
Spirit
Deuteronomy
32:4 all right give my little brothers
time to find
it it's 20 to 4 you have it now my good
Brothers read with me he
is he is the his wake is all his ways
are a god of yes and not a a god of TR
truth and without iniquity the father is
a god of Truth Jesus says I am truth the
Bible says the holy spirit is truth what
else did Jesus say he is I am the way
the truth and the life let's go to John
6 let's read verse
57 John 6 verse 57
do we have that this is Jesus
speaking read with me as the living
father have sent me is the word living
capitalized or does it begin with a
capital
letter H
yes as the living now I am a living
human being but I don't have life
naturally God is the living God because
life comes from him he is life Jesus
says I am
life now go to Romans
8 Romans
8 mhm we read from verse one of Romans 8
we're looking at the Trinity and the
spirit
particularly Romans 8 from verse one
when you found it say Amen there is
therefore now no condemnation to them
which are in Christ Jesus who walked not
after the flesh but after the spirit for
the law of the spirit of life in Christ
Jesus what's the spirit called the
spirit of life and so we have the Living
God he's the god of life we have Christ
I am the life and we have the spirit
he's the spirit of
Life whatever God is as a Divine being
the holy spirit is whatever Jesus is as
a Divine being the spirit is because
Father Son and Holy Ghost are three
Divine
beings those of you who just came in we
said earlier they have different
responsibilities and levels of authority
so it's the Father the Son the spirit
but with respect to Divinity they are
fully Divine equal one to the other they
just differ in the functions they carry
out spirit of God is a separate being
from the son as the son is a separate
being from the
father I've said many times this evening
there are people who believe the Trinity
is really one person expressing himself
three different
ways what's the common title for Christ
in the New Testament he's the
son of God what does that mean did he
have a Divine
mother no let's go to uh John 17 let's
read verse 12 let's try to understand
what the Bible means by Jesus is the son
of
God you have John
17 Reading verse
12 now Christ is praying to the father
he's praying for the disciples while I
was with them in the world I kept them
in thy name those that thou gavest me I
have kept and none of them is lost
finish the verse but the son of
predition now predition is
destruction who is the son of predition
Judas but why is he called the son of
predition hold on to your horses let's
go to 2 Thessalonians chapter
2 then we'll understand what is meant by
Jesus is the son of God without having a
Divine
mother Islam has difficulty with Christ
as the Son of God because they say he
cannot have a mother being God but
they're right he has no mother as God he
has no mother 2 Thessalonians 2 let's
read from verse
one when you found it say
Amen now we beseech you Brethren by the
coming of the Lord Jesus Christ and by
our what gather together in him that you
be not soon shaken in mind or be
troubled neither by Spirit nor my word
nor by letter as from us that the day of
Christ is at hand let no man deceive you
by any means for that they shall not
come except they come of following away
first now carefully and that man of sin
be revealed keep
reading ah the son of now who is that
that's the Antichrist Paul is talking
about he calls him the son of
predition Jesus called Judas the son of
predition because Judas had the same
mind as the Antichrist
are you following me he had the same
intentions towards God as the Antichrist
has towards God and so Jesus calls Judas
the son of predition Because by his
behavior and his thinking he reflected
the son of predition the Antichrist why
were James and John called the sons of
thunder did Thunder give birth to
them why were they called the sons of
thunder because in the early time with
Christ when he first met them they were
they loveed to fight fight they were
boisterous and noisy loved to
fight and so Christ called them son's
ofender now keeping this in mind why do
you think Jesus is the son of
God
huh why do you think Jesus is called the
Son of
God he is just like God Judas is a son
of predition because he was just like
the Antichrist who was called a son of
predition James and John were called the
sons of thunder because the character
was like thunder and so Jesus is the son
of God because he's just like the
father are you following
me in John 8:44 Jesus says ye are of
your father the devil he was speaking
mainly to men each one was a son of the
devil why because in the attitude of
Christ they reflected the
devil son of in case of Christ simply
means just
like not that Christ had the mother
before he became
human he is just like the father so he's
the son of the father because they're
very
much alike all right it's uh something
to four about 10 minutes
what have you heard me say someone who's
not yet responded what have you heard
what have you learned this
afternoon now don't break my heart you
must have learned
something yes oh where yes my
brother yes by the way the Sinner and SA
have the same
mind Judas the son of predition the
Antichrist the son of
predition
mhm
yes
uhhuh go
ahead
yes
John oh good question good
question mhm
say it again say it
again uhhuh why John baptized the name
of Jesus
only now the Bible doesn't say now Jesus
was being baptized as a human being as a
our representative as a sinner you see
so John could baptize in the name of the
person he's baptizing because Christ was
submitting to the authority so he
couldn't baptized in the name of Jesus
but Jesus before he left he told us
baptized for inst in the Old Testament
there wasn't baptism are you following
me there wasn't baptism so up to that
point there wasn't the father son Holy
Ghost but after Jesus came as a
representative he said look baptize in
the name of the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit but John did not have to do that
so John didn't do that no but he did it
at the request of Jesus you understand
me Jesus said do it and he did it in
that sense he found in the name of Jesus
mhm you had a second
question we baptized in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit we
baptized in the name of Jesus M we do
didn't you hear the pastor this
after
only because Jesus said baptize in the
name of the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit that's what Jesus said now you're
asking me why do we not disobey Jesus is
that what you're asking me no we can't
disobey Jesus Jesus said the Father the
Son the Holy
Ghost now let me take a little minute on
this let me pray again
father help me to make this very simple
in Jesus name I pray
amen that is based on Acts chapter 19
I've heard that before go to Acts
chapter
19 remember the third favor I always ask
you what is that think and reason okay
Acts
19 read verse
5 when they heard this they were
baptized in the name of the Lord Jesus
now people use that to say
ah Paul did not baptize the name of the
Father the Son the Holy Spirit okay
let's look at that before someone else
says Ah let's look at
that let's go to uh what are the two
famous cities for idolatry and
immorality what are they Sodom and
Gomorrah
let's actually see how many cities there
were let's go to John Genesis 14 you
have to observe some things about Bible
writers Genesis
14 I have Genesis
14 let's read from verse
one and it came to pass in the days of
of am Rafel king of Shina arot king of
elaser koloma king of Elam and title
king of Nations that these made war with
barah king of Sodom and with Bersa king
of Gomorrah shab king of admer shimba
king of zeboim and the king of baa which
is zoah how many cities do we have five
now go to the book of Jude let's read
verse six
Jude let's read verse
six are you there read with me and the
angels no not verse six verse 7 even as
Sodom and Gomorrah keep reading and the
cities about them in like manner in
other words what happened to Sodom gorah
happened to those cities because they
were all the same with respect to sin
but only to a mention the writer does
not want to mention all five he just
mentions two but those two tell us we
have to include the others are you
following me all right let's go to
Romans chapter
13 Romans
13 let's read verse
8 from 8 to9
of Romans
13 owe no man anything but to love one
another for he that loveth another hath
fulfill the law for this Thou shalt not
commit adultery Thou shalt not kill Thou
shalt not steal Thou shalt not bear
false witness Thou shalt not covet and
if there be any other commandment it is
briefly comprehended in this saying Thou
shalt love thy neighbor as thyself now
how many Commandments did Christ
quote come on how many did he literally
quote look at the verse
he we mentioned five but we know where
did the five come from the 10 command is
he excluding the other
five if I were to say to you name
identify the country keep man sh volis
Bay what would you say immediately
Namibia do I need to name all the towns
no go to Psalm
106 Psalm 106
let's read verse
17 let's read verse 17 of Psalm 106 what
does that say the Earth opened and
swallowed up home and covered the
company of AUM now who would the princes
that rebelled against God do you know
the
names Kora Dayan and abam which name is
not mentioned in there Kora but do we
understand he's included
yes now they baptized him in the name of
Jesus what do you have to understand the
Father the Son are included but just not
mentioned no need to keep mentioning all
the time all the time all the time
that's why throughout the Bible the five
cities of the Plains are represented by
Sodom and Gomorrah over and over but we
know it includes all five so when you
see baptized name of Jesus you have to
put in father and
spirit
mhm all right it's uh 5 to 4 we have to
get to the
Q&A I need to breathe a little
bit have another Q&A right after this at
8:00 for church in New York all right
sister Esther come
before well before we need a chister
come sing one
song any CHS no not one oh
okay then we'll get into the Q&A I'll go
get my bottle of water is the office
open right
back all right
350 350
how is the
energy you are there let's keep
on let's keep on we need to start eating
proper
food this thing of eating
eating things that I think we need to
follow Elder we are
there blessed be the ti that binds our
hearts in creation love together blessed
be the maybe we can we just stand maybe
just to a little bit to stretch
yes yes yes
yes I wanted to say if you are happy
anymore clap your hands if you are happy
anymore clap your
hands
hey my daughter come and do that so that
maybe just to that's the song I think
you know it better than me if you are
happy so
that we get the energy back for the next
session well let's just skip it all
right God is good
good all the time do you know the Little
Chorus the things I used to do the
things I used to do why do them no more
the things I used to do why do them no
more the things I used to do I do them
no more there's a great change since
I've been
born there's a great change since I've
been born there's a great change since
I've been born there's a great change
since I've been born there's a great
change since I've been
born the friends I used to keep I keep
them no more the friends I used to keep
I keep them no more the friends I used
to keep I keep them no more there's a
great chance since I've been
born there's a great change since I've
been born there's a great change since
I've been born there's a great change
since I've been born there's a great
change since I been
born you may be seated
down all
right let me make a an unpleasant
announcement are you
ready during the week we told you submit
your questions ahead of time did we do
that yes or no all right so we're not
taking questions from the congregation
we're only dealing with the ones that
were submitted and are on this sheet are
you following me all right you look
unhappy but that's the rule for today
only the questions on this sheet okay
sister Esther come you can sit let me
pray first father
James 1: 15 says if any of you lack
wisdom let him ask of God give me the
wisdom I pray in Jesus name amen
question
one does living in sin stop God from
answering prayers especially big prayer
requests that require Deliverance those
living in sin prevent God from answering
prayers go to Proverbs
28 uh Psalm 66 sorry verse 18 psalm
66:18 does living in sin prevent God
from answering prayers Psalm
66:18 do we have
that read with me if I regard iniquity
in my
heart the Lord will not hear me
now go to Isaiah chapter
1 in Isaiah chapter 1 God is criticizing
the Israelites for bringing all these
sacrifices without bringing their hearts
you see so the sacrifices were
meaningless here's what he says to them
in verse 15 of Isaiah 1 what does that
say Isaiah 1:15 says what and when ye
spread forth your hands I will hide my
face from your ear my eyes from your ear
when you make many prayers I will not
hear why because of all the sins they
were
practicing Isaiah 59 read from verse
one Isaiah
59 reading from verse one we're
answering the question do active sins
interfere with God's answering of
prayers
Isaiah 59 reading from verse one behold
the Lord's hand is not shortened that he
cannot save come on neither his ear
heavy that he cannot hear but your
iniquities have separated between you
and your God and His your sins have hid
his face from you finish the verse that
he will not hear there's one thing that
blocks prayers from being answered it's
active
sin you want your prayers
answered get your sins
confessed
forgiven you see God cannot be
manipulated God is not someone you just
toss around live any life you want and
then ask for everything you want from
God someone wrote me very disappointed a
relationship did not work out and he
wrote me he said I don't understand I
asked God to bless my
plans so I wrote back and said next time
ask God to reveal his plans for you
don't ask God to bless your plans
because you don't know what a good plan
is ask God to reveal his
plan so he's disappointed God didn't
bless my plans but he wasn't aware of
what he was saying you see oh no God
doesn't exist to bless our plans we
should go to God and ask him what is
your plan for me or if you have a plan
you say father do you approve not just
bless my plan do you
approve you stay out of a lot of trouble
that way next
question can a prayer be answered if we
do not ask in the name of Jesus Christ
John 14:13-14
in the times of ignorance God
overlooks when a person genuinely does
not know God
overlooks but to him that knoweth to do
good and doeth it not it is sin you see
Jesus tells us ask in his name there's a
reason for
that there is nothing God can do for you
or for me unless it is done through
Jesus
Christ now this was his before sin but
when Adam sinned everything that God
through Jesus Christ and so his name
represent is his life his divinity is as
the name of Jesus Christ the one who
paid the penalty for my sins the one who
sacrificed satisfied the father in the
name of Jesus it is not Abracadabra to
open any whatever it is not open sesame
that's not what the name of Jesus is the
name of Jesus is your acknowledgment of
his divinity his Humanity his role as
Creator his role as Savior his sinless
life in the name of
Jesus when you know you should and you
don't you danger the possibility of
having your prayers answered because God
is not the author of confusion God does
things in a very disciplined way really
he
does all right so please pray in the
name of Jesus not in the name of the
father I've heard people pray father do
this do that in your name I
pray in the name of Jesus and people do
that because they're not conscious of
the tremendous significance of praying
in the name of Jesus
Jesus but you must have a relationship
with him in Acts chapter 19 there were
some exorcists professional Exorcist
they noticed that Paul cast out demons
in the name of Jesus so they tried and
they said in the name of Jesus that Paul
talks about because they didn't know
Christ personally the demons started to
beat these men all seven ran out of the
house naked and
bleeding just saying Jesus does not have
power because a lot of men in Hispanic
countries are called Jus are you
following me is j s s you have to
understand who is he what did he stand
for what does he do now that's the name
of Jesus when you know you should do it
all right because anything Jesus puts to
the father on your behalf the father
will answer anything Christ takes to the
father on your behalf the father will
answer next question how do I pray
effectively for my marriage family life
and over my children you pray through
the word of God read the question again
please how do I pray effectively for my
marriage family life and over my
children you pray biblically here's what
I
mean when um when
Jehoshaphat was threatened by a large
army go to 2 Chronicles chapter
20 2 Chronicles chapter
20 let's read from verse 6 now the
ammonites and two other
armies they came to attack the kingdom
of Judah Jehoshaphat called all the
citizens to Jerusalem they gather around
the temple and Jehoshaphat starts to
pray to God about this
threat read verse six what does that
say come on read out loud
and said oh
lord of our father are not
thou
stop what is Jehoshaphat
doing is there any Bible verse that says
God is the god of Heaven Come on yes now
he says oh Lord God of our fathers art
not thou God in heaven what is he V
virtually
quoting Bible
verse so he's confronting God with his
word aren't you God in heaven the Bible
says he is what do you think God said if
you can listen with the ear of Faith
what you need hear God saying yes read
the next
statement not not Thou come on read let
me hear
you rulest not thou over all the
kingdoms does the bible say that yes
what do you hear God saying yes you read
all the way down to verse 11 of verse 10
Jehoshaphat just reminds didn't you do
this didn't you say didn't you say that
and God has to keep saying yes yes
yes then he tells God do something for
us and did God do it
yes praying through the Bible for
instance let's say your child has left
the
church you say dear God you've said in
Isaiah
49:25 I will save thy children
please go get my child you do it your
way it may cause pain you do
it you're
broke you say father didn't you
say I will pour you out a blessing they
shall not be room enough to didn't you
say that what does God have to say
yes when you pray whether for your
marriage your children pray
biblically are you following me but you
have to know the Bible verses next
necessary or you thought you have to
study the word of God to pray biblically
you must know the word of God so whether
you pray you pray over your marriage
father didn't you say in Malachi 21:16
the Lord God of Israel hateth putting
away now my wife is acting up my husband
is acting up there's a possibility of
divorce didn't you say you hate putting
away well father do
something pray Through the Bible because
when you present present god with his
word God has no option but to act God
will never deny his word it's not a way
of painting God into a corner do you
have that expression okay it is simply
saying this is what you
said you said that stick by it please
you'll be surprised God will never deny
his word regardless of what you pray for
pray through the word of God bu you but
you must know the
word because praying is not an isolated
act just to get you what you want
praying is fellowship with God are you
with me whether you need anything or not
and we always need Grace next
question as the head of my household how
do I run it effectively and in the way
of
God you lead out
spiritually as a head of the
household you're the head of the house
you're not the tyrant
you're not the boss you're the head and
biblical headship is service are you
following me so you have to lead out in
spiritual things you've got to set the
example so that you lead that way let's
go to Ephesians chapter
5 may I take a sip of this you know I
hate doing it but I've been talking all
day is that okay all
right Ephesians 5
let's read from verse 22 what does that
say Wives come on submit yourselves to
your own husbands as unto the Lord for
the husband come on is the head of the
wife even as Christ is the head of the
church now carefully now and he is the
savior of the body the husband is the
savior of the body of the family as
verily as Christ is the savior of the
body the church
now finish the
verse let's read verse 25 husbands love
your wives even as Christ also loved the
church and gave himself for it
now any woman will follow a man who's
willing to die for her are you following
me not willing to kill her willing to
die for her as Christ was prepared and
actually died for the church now you ask
the husband how should he lead out he
leads out by example first spiritually
because a man is the priest make sure
the family prays in the morning prays at
night make sure the children are taught
the word make sure the children are
taken to church and not
sent you're not listening to me don't
send them to church take them to
church don't hire someone to teach them
the Bible you teach them
leadership be begins spiritually
first much prayer with the family and by
yourself Christ would rise early at
night or early in the morning when
everyone was sleeping to pray a
spiritual father while the mother is
snoring and the children are snoring
he's in some corner of the house come on
praying because he's the house band are
you with me he's the house band
he's not a boss he's a head and headship
in the Bible is service so Christ said
even as the son of man came not to be
ministered unto but to
minister first spiritually the word of
God family that lives by the word of God
is a family Bound for the
kingdom the father cannot put his career
above the spiritual welfare of the
family if he does that he should not
have had a family
all right next
question if one pays lobola or doy for a
wife and obtains a marriage certificate
via court is this Union still blessed by
God well I come from a culture with no
Lola so but for what from what I've
learned and picked up but I don't speak
with
authority there are two levels of
recognition in many African cultures the
traditional and the formal or
governmental uh I was counseling a
couple online several uh about a year
ago and they told me we paid Lola and
according to tradition we recognize as
matter I said well I don't know if you
recognize you recognize make sure the
government recognizes That Then I then
they said later on we'll have a church
service so you have to find out what the
culture tradition is because I don't
know is maybe different in Zimbabwe from
Angola mosque South Africa BW maybe I
don't know but you find out what is uh
the tradition
and you make sure you behave
appropriately we don't want you living
together when you're not really husband
and wife so just familiarize yourself
with the customs of both the culture and
what the government
requires because you must be married in
the sight not only of your tribe but
also of the government under which you
you are living and also as a Christian
in the sight of
God let me say something no I won't say
it go ahead next question
no no no no no no no no no no when the
spirit says don't say it don't say it
all right next question do dreams in our
times still have meaning and if so what
does it mean to always be running from
danger do dreams still have meaning in
our time God can give a dream to anyone
he wants let me say this quickly don't
depend on dreams when God gave dreams to
Pharaoh back in Genesis 39 uh 41 and he
gave dreams to Nebuchadnezzar there was
no Bible
are you following me there was no Bible
but as the Bible was developed first the
Old Testament then the new you'll
observe that dreams became fewer and
fewer and fewer God's primary means of
communication is thus Seth the Lord not
dreams now I did not say God never gives
dreams I simply said God's primary
method of communication is his word if
we all depended on dreams we would put
the Bible on the Shelf
and God will not develop a situation
that causes you and me to skirt around
his word this is how he
communicates primarily but God can
choose to give an individual a Dream
from time to time I don't know what it
means to be what running from danger
maybe if you confess your sins you'll
have different dreams but I don't know
what it means to be constantly running
from danger and I don't I'm not Daniel
but don't depend on dreams talk to God
through his word next
question is there anything such as
rebaptism I was baptized in 2015 and
since then have lived a sinful life I am
ashamed of it and would like to start a
fresh please advise well we read in Acts
Chapter 19 Verse 5 when they heard this
they were baptized in the name of the
Lord Jesus there were 12 disciples whom
Paul re-baptized because there was vital
Bible information they did not have he
taught them and he re-baptized them now
Ela white writes in uh evangelism page
375 paragraph 2 when a soul is truly
reconverted let that Soul be re-baptized
so rebaptism is in the Bible and the
writings of our Prophet Ellen White but
don't get re-baptized each time you
sneeze or anything of the kind that's
not what she's saying if there's a Recon
you know some people come to church
Faithfully but they have no connection
with Christ let me tell you the story I
was in a South Korea preaching for a
weekend made a call for baptism and
rebaptism 50s something people
came to
rebaptism and I took them to a room to
speak to them and a retired Minister
joined me he was from South Africa and
he gave a personal experience he said in
the middle of his ministry he went to
the conference president and requested
to be re-baptized well naturally the
president was taken aback and he began
to wonder what did this man do he said
I've done nothing but my life has not
grown in 20 years
I run the church meet my goals the tithe
is up but I have not grown I want to
start again with my God the president
said well let's baptize you at night so
nobody sees he said no no no no no no no
baptize me in the day right in front of
my church because there are people in my
church who need to make the same
decision who have never grown in all
this
time I was at another church somewhere
preaching a week of prayer the associ
Pastor got re-baptized because he was
reconverted I was in another place
during a week of prayer the pastor's
wife and son got re-baptized and he
re-baptized both of them rebaptism is
perfectly uh biblical and perfectly
legitimate all right but don't make it a
weekly habit that's what I'm trying to
tell
you please explain John 3: 1-7 the text
implies we are all born sinners and no
man can see the kingdom of God unless
they are born of water and the Holy
Spirit the SDA church does not baptize
young children therefore will they enter
Heaven should they die at that age many
a time in the Bible God punished and
destroyed cities babies included because
of the decisions of the parents MH all
right John 31-7 there was a man of the
Pharisees named Nicodemus a ruler of the
Jews the same came to Jesus by night and
said unto him Rabbi we know that thou
are a teacher sent from God for no man
can do these Miracles which thou doest
except God be with him Jesus answered
and said unto him verily verily I say
unto you except a man be born again he
cannot see the kingdom of God Nicodemus
saith unto him how can a man be born
when he's old can he enter the second
time into his mother's womb and be born
Jesus answered verily verily I say unto
you except a man be born of water and of
the spirit he cannot enter the kingdom
of God can't see it can't enter it that
which is is born of the flesh is flesh
that which is born of the spirit is
Spirit now the question says we're born
sinners now I need to respond to that
carefully it is more accurate to say
we're all born in need of a
savior no one is born guilty of Adam's
sin that's called Original Sin the
church does not believe that no one is
born guilty of Adam's sin we are all
born with a condition that needs a
savior to Deliver Us from it every
single human being needs a savior if a
baby is born and a baby is born in a
coma and is attached to a machine and a
baby lives 15 years on that machine that
baby still needs a
savior even though he or she has never
made a moral choice to offend God once
you were born into this world since Adam
sinned you need a savior but no one is
born guilty of Adam's sin we do not
believe in original sin now when babies
die yes God has requested on occasions
everyone be killed in a particular city
or town he is done that but God knows
the end from the beginning God knows
what that child would become had the
child lived but ultimately even if we
can't explain it we know from Psalm
145:17 the Lord is righteous in all his
ways and holy in all his works whatever
God does is right even though we do not
understand our understanding is limited
and I mean severely limited when it
comes to understanding the actions of
God anything God does is
right so we don't know what will happen
to the babies we do know that God is a
merciful god I will have mercy unto whom
I will have mercy we do know that God is
very unwilling that anyone should perish
we do know that God doesn't punish the
innocent because of the misbehavior of
the guilty that's as far as I can
go some say the seventh day Adventists
are a branch of the Catholicism how do
we know it is the true church some say
what the Seventh Day Adventist is a
branch branch of the Catholic church
church yes what's the opposite to Black
what's the opposite to tall what's the
opposite to Fat come on what's the
opposite to Sweet what's the opposite to
Adventist
yeah you better believe it we are not a
brge of the Catholic church we were
raised up to expose the man of sin are
you with me we were raised up as an
antidote when I say antidote as an agent
under the control of Christ to work
against what the Beast does or the man
of sin or the two or the uh the little
horn in Daniel 7 or the leopard likee
beast in Revelation 13 that's our
function to
oppose all the errors that flow from the
Roman Church we are not an extension not
now some of us behave that
way there a lot of Adventists who were
Adventist Catholics and the Adventist
Pentecostals and the Adventist atheists
and the Adventist vegetarians who love
meat they are all kinds of
things but the Adventist Church as God
raised it up is the precise opposite to
the Roman
Church how do you know we're the true
church of
god let's look at the church the devil
hat hates are you following
me did you hear what I said let's look
at the church the devil hates go to
Revelation
12 Revelation
12 we read from verse
7 and there was war in heaven where did
the war again in heaven Michael and his
angels fought against the dragon and the
dragon fought and his angels and
prevailed not neither was their place
found anymore in heaven and the Great
Dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth the whole world he was cast
out into the Earth and his angels were
cast out with him verse 7 says a War
began in heaven now let's read verse
13 and when the dragon saw that he was
cast where un the Earth he persecuted
the woman come on which brought forth
The Man Child
now in heaven whom do Satan fight
directly come on
Jesus you see Adventists have a way of
interpreting the Bible it's called the
Great
controversy everything that happens on
Earth generally and in your life
personally puts you on one side or other
of the great controversy the great
controversy is a battle between come on
Christ and Satan it began long before
the world was made it continues today
now it began in heaven but Satan was
thrown out so he transferred his
hostility to the earth now he cannot
reach Christ directly so he hurts Christ
how by the church you see he hurts the
church and thereby hurts
Christ you prefer me to slap you than to
slap the baby in your
arms are you listening to me if I were
to slap that baby in your arm you'd feel
it more than the baby and that would be
the last day of my life on this Earth
are you following me Satan gets to God
or to Christ by hurting the church and
so now verse 17 says verse 13 says he
persecuted the woman that brought forth
the Manchild now that's the early church
but the early church have Generations
that descended descended descended Now
read verse 17 and the dragon was Roth
with the woman and went to make war with
the remnant of her seed which keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ now we have
the Commandments of God the testimony of
Jesus Christ he made he went to make war
with the remnant of her seed now keep in
mind Revelation has many many women
symbolizing churches you say to me
explain that go to Revelation
17 Revelation 17 we'll read verse 5 this
is about Babylon the great or the
great system of false religions and
false
worship me read from verse four and the
woman was arrayed in purple and scarlet
color and decked with gold precious
stone and pearls having a golden cup in
her hand full of Abominations and
filthiness of a fornication Revelation
174 Now read verse 5 and upon her
forehead come on was a name written
mystery Babylon the great carefully now
the mother of
harlots that's fine and Abominations of
the Earth the mother of harlots Babylon
has many daughters but cats give birth
to little cats are you with me are you
Lions give birth to little Li
Lions Babylon gives birth to little
Babylon ettes is
that they're just like she is so in fact
Revelation has many women many false
churches but Revelation 12:17 says and
the dragon was wroth come on with the
woman not the
women I may be politically incorrect but
I'll say it
boldly Satan is mad
as a
Hatter with one
church the church that highlights the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ in the in the
ministry of someone with the prophetic
gift and that church is a 7eventh Day
Adventist
Church no other church on the face of
the Earth defends and upholds the law of
God I'll tell you something else why you
can reasonably conclude which church is
God's Church go to Matthew 28
Matthew 28 reading from verse
18 you have that not yet all
right you have it
now and Jesus came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me come
on in heaven and in Earth go ye
therefore and teach most Nations All
Nations now where did Christ send his
disciples what is All Nations the whole
world the Church of Christ should be
found where all over the world listen to
me carefully there are only two
churches that come close to meeting that
requirement two name them the Catholic
church and the adst
church the United Nations lists about
230 countries as separate Sovereign
Nations about 230 the S Adventist Church
is in about roughly 210 of
them the only other church that comes
close is a Catholic
Church forget the others and I speak
with respect now you've got you've got a
choice the Catholic Church qualifying as
God's church end time church or the 7day
Adventist Church listen to me carefully
the end time Church keeps the
Commandments of God are you with me
let's look at the Commandments of
God there are 10 of them God has never
changed them has the Catholic Church
changed God's law yes or no yes give me
an
example the fourth one they moved they
said they moved the Sal they said from
the seventh day to the first but only
God can make something holy are you with
me no human being can make something
holy and so they keep Sunday secular
they can't keep it holy I tell you
something what other change do they make
in God's
law the what Idols they removed
commandment two because commandment two
forbids the making and worship of idols
and so in the Catholic catechism it does
not
appear which meant now they had nine
Commandments instead of 10 what did they
do they went to commandment 10 and split
it into two commandment 10 says Thou
shalt not cover thy neighbor's house
Thou shalt not cover thy neighbor's wife
or his man servant maid servant Ox ass
whatever nor anything that is thy
neighbors the church split that into two
and said one is thou shall not cover thy
neighbor's wife thou shall not cover thy
neighbor's house they made that two
Commandments but reason with me if you
do that you have to make every element
in that commandment a commandment
because it said Thou shalt not cover thy
neighbor's house th sh not have
neighbor's wife nor his man servant nor
his maid servant nor his o nor his ass
nor anything that is thy neighbors each
one has to be a commandment if you start
splitting them I hope you're following
me so the church split the 10 into two
to come up with the original
10 let me show you something
else that the church has done with
respect to God's
law in the Catholic version of The Ten
Commandments as in their cath now in
their Bible is the same thing as in your
Bible but most instruction is not out of
the Bible it is out of the catechism are
you following
me what did you just say are you
following me all right in the catechism
give me the first four Commandments in
the Catholic catechism just short
versions Thou shalt have no other gods
before me that's correct
two
what Thou shalt not take the name of the
Lord God in vain that's two in your
Bible that's that's three what's number
three for
them remember the Sabbath day what's
number four honor your father and your
mother okay listen to me
carefully on the Catholic table you know
Moses was given two tables on their
first table they have no gods don't take
God's name in vain keep the Sabbath day
holy but that's all they right they
never they never go on to say which day
it is they just say keep the Sabbath
holy that's it and number four is honor
thy father and thy mother now in the
Bible version honor thy father and thy
mother is on what stone what table the
second table for whom is the first table
demonstrating of uh affection and
loyalty and God the first four is pecul
are for peculiarly for God service
relationship with God the second six
your fellow man but in the Catholic
version as in the
catechism where is where are father and
mother
found in the first table which shows
Love For
Whom so they've put father on mother on
the Divine side are you are you are you
following me under the Now who is the
Holy
Father you know he's God on
Earth yeah he's God on Earth according
to their he's God on Earth he then is on
the first table
that's reserved for
God in the Bible mother and father are
on the second
table so we have a man occupying the
spot that should be occupied by
God because in their mind the pope is
verily God on Earth you cannot get more
Blasphemous so even though that church
compete with our church with respect to
its presence all over the world its
relationship with God's law disqualifies
it from being
considered God's last day Church what
else can I give to you to make a correct
Choice the doctrines of that
church does the church allow you to pray
to Saints yes or no because they believe
that Saints are alive but we know the
Bible teaches when you're dead you're
dead until Christ raises you up the
church allows you to talk to Mary
because Mary is a sort of assistant
savior if you don't get something from
Christ ask Mary and she'll get it for
you the church says a priest can forgive
your sins the Bible says who can forgive
sins but
God the church says in communion the
wine and the wafer literally become the
blood and the body of Jesus and the
Bible says don't drink blood not even
Jesus is BL don't drink
blood the church says there's a place
called
Purgatory it's not heaven it's not hell
is a place where you go before you're
finally qualified for heaven Purgatory
was developed by Augustine who lived
from 354 to 430 ad about 3 to 400 years
after Christ that's who developed
purgatory and it entered into the
Catholic teaching Purgatory is not in
the Bible that Church believes that
Sinners go to hell and they burn how
long
forever the Bible says the wages of sin
is death not Eternal burning someone
burning forever is not
dead am I talking to
myself but that church says Sinners burn
forever and ever and ever and ever the
Bible says behold I come quickly and my
reward is with me to give every man
according as his work which means god is
proportional who has sinned forever and
ever nobody then nobody can burn forever
and ever because he gives according to
their work but let me see how let let me
show you how good God is who has been
righteous forever and ever none of us
but we live with Christ for how long ah
forever so God blesses forever but he
punishes for a short
time the Catholic Church the Adventist
Church you look at the evidence the
Adventist Church represents God's last
day Church God's Remnant Church on this
Earth
next
question but let me say quickly when we
say the Catholic Church the Roman Church
we are not referring to the members in
the
pews they have no clue what is the
magisterium you ask the the average
Catholic in the Pew what is the
magisterium and they can tell you the
maester refers to the pope and the
Bishops as the authority to explain the
Bible
that's the the fundamental meaning in
the Catholic Church the Bible is not the
highest
Authority that was settled at the
Council of Trent which ran from 1545 to
1563 on and off for 18 years at the
Council of Trent it was established that
tradition is as high as the Bible itself
and sometimes even higher the Bible is
not the highest Authority in the
Catholic Church any honest priest will
tell you that in the 7ay Adventist
Church the the Bible is the highest
Authority yes we have counsel from our
servant but the Bible is the highest and
final
Authority all
right next question oh I I didn't finish
I said we're not talking to the members
in the PE we're talking to the system
that's located where in the Vatican
which has continued for over a thousand
years 1,500 and more has continued
continued continued that's why the
Antichrist is not a person no one has
lived that long the Antichrist is a
system and not a political system really
it is a religious system and the devil
is so clever he uses a religious system
because no one would expect a religious
system to persecute other
churches next
question when the Bible talks about the
mark of the beast is that a literal Mark
or the forehead and hands please
elaborate the mark of the beast and then
there's the mark of the Seal of God the
Seal of God is a
Sabbath the Sabbath commandment has his
name his territory his title Creator
Heaven and Earth he's
God the mark of the beast and that is in
the writings of the Catholic Church they
say their
Mark you can find out out very very
quickly on YouTube on uh to Google it
their Mark of authority is the fact that
they changed the Sabbath from Saturday
to Sunday in other words they change
what God said that's a mark of authority
that they can take what God Said and
change it that's what they say a mark of
authority to change God's law now their
Mark is not a visible Mark in the hand
or the head the Bible says it's on the
hand or the forehead the hand means you
do it mechanically the forehead means
you really believe this error the seal
of God is in the hand in Deuteronomy
chapter 6 bind it for front it around
thine eyes and also be upon your hand
the gates of your house your post the
door
everywhere the God's sign is a Sabbath
we know from uh Exodus 31:13 to1 17
verily my Sabbath they shall keep for
there sign between me and you throughout
your Generations that you may know that
I am the Lord that to sanctify you the
Sabbath is a sign of San
sanctification
now when God I am I tell you too much
all right let me tell you when God made
Creation in six days rest of the seventh
the seventh only became holy after God
rested are you with
me he blessed it when he had finished
his rest in other words he rested the
entire day first then he blessed it it
was not blessed while he was
resting so in effect we had seven
secular
days at the end of his rest then he
blessed that seventh day he made a
secular day holy Ela white writes God
rested first then he blessed it and gave
it to
mankind now the Sabbath is a signed I'm
the Lord to sanctify you the same way he
Sanctified a secular Day made it holy he
can sanctify our secular lives are you
with me it is a sign that God is able to
sanctify us now when you accept Sunday
as your day of worship you have accepted
the authority of an organization that
opposes God and God's word despite
whatever else they may say when you
undertake to change God's law and in any
country the laws are the principles by
which that country functions and those
laws are condensed in what is called the
constitution of Any Nation when you
interfere with God's Constitution you
threaten his
kingdom the church has changed
it at the Council of
Trent 1545
1563 that Council was called for a
couple reasons or three reasons mainly
one to highlight Catholic teachings and
to undermine Protestant beliefs two
to try to get rid of all the abuses and
corruption in the church and to develop
some principles of operation for that
church but the main one was to undermine
Protestant teaching and to establish
Catholic teaching the council ended with
the Catholic church triumphing over the
Protestants with this argument there was
a bishop called the bishop of Regio
Catholic bishop here's what he said to
the
Protestants because the Protestants had
a war cry it was
solar scriptura what does that mean the
Bible only this Catholic bishop got up
towards the end after 18 years he said
you Protestants you claim the Bible
only yet you keep Sunday as the Sabbath
for which the Bible gives no
Authority are you following me when he
said that the Protestants had nothing to
say you claim solar scriptura Bishop
Regio said
yet you accept our Authority and we
change the day without any Bible
Authority whatsoever we establish our
authority over the Bible and you accept
it by observing
Sunday anyone who knowingly keeps Sunday
is accepting and Authority above God
that is called the mark of the beast but
let me say something quickly no one
actually has the mark of the beast now
because there isn't n a formal worldwide
law requiring Sabbath observance but
that is
coming when that comes because that has
been agitated for decades quietly
Nations have tried to pass Sunday laws
to make Sunday the legal day of worship
it will happen when it happens then we
have to make a choice a man-made law or
God's law those who then choose a
man-made law would have chosen the mark
of the beast but as now no one has the
mark the Beast because that man-made law
is not yet
enforced the Seal of God the Sabbath
acknowledging God is Creator and savior
sustainer Almighty and divine and having
a right to rule the universe the Sabbath
is a sign between God and his people
Sunday is a sign between people and the
Catholic Church even if you're
Pentecostal
because Pentecostal skip Sunday the
Pentecostal Church began about 1903 1904
somewhere in the first decade of the
1900s that's when they began the
Catholic church was in existence over a
thousand years before that and having
put Sunday into the world the
Pentecostals came and adopted Sunday the
the Presbyterians came and adopted
Sunday the Methodist came and adopted
Sunday you name it the the Baptist came
adopted Sunday the Jehovah's Witnesses
came adopted Sunday the Mormons came
adopted Sunday the Holy Rollers came
adopted Sunday bushiri came adopted
Sunday H each adoption of Sunday is an
adoption of the authority of the
Catholic Church no matter what else they
may
say you've accepted a power that places
itself above
God sometimes I say Pentecostals are
Catholics because they worship on the
Catholic day again can I say is the
Catholic Church's day in the Council of
Leo deia 364 ad about 340 years after
Jesus went back to heaven the council
met and made it illegal to worship on
Sabbath the punishment for that was
being cast out of God's kingdom how they
could do that I don't know the Seventh
Day Adventist Church one of the reasons
Christ came Isaiah 42:21 is to magnify
the law and make it honorable
all
10 all right that was a long
response what does the Sabbath was made
for man and not man for the Sabbath mean
let me say something else about this the
Sabbath let me come back let me I didn't
finish go to John six let me show you
something we read verse 66
of John
6 verse
66 are you there read with me please
from that time many of his disciples
went back and walked no more with him
they left Jesus now why because Jesus
kept saying Eat My Flesh and drink my
blood they did not understand what he
meant now the Jews didn't drink blood
the Jews were not cannibals so when he
said drink my blood and eat my flesh
they were I mean they were shocked
so they left him many of us don't
understand the words of Christ that we
don't leave him physically but we leave
him in the
mind then said Jesus unto the 12 verse
67 will he also go away read 68 for me
nice and loud then Simon Peter said what
Lord to whom shall we go thou Hast the
words of eternal life pause think with
me here's question what was the reason
Peter gave for staying with
Christ what he was
preaching thou Hast the words of eternal
life which means when you choose a
church the only question you need to ask
is what do they
teach not if there's a grand piano or if
they have a choir or if the pastor
drives or flies with a little plane what
do they teach not if the members are
perfect Jesus said have I not not chosen
you 12 one of you is a devil Jesus was
the pastor of the early church one of
his members was a devil but that church
was still the Church of God because the
teachings were
biblical when you look at the Adventist
Church what we preach is biblical are we
all Saints oh no do we have some judases
yes they didn't come today but we have
some judases are you with all right next
question what does the Sabbath was made
for men and not men for the Sab all
right did you have Heroes day
yesterday okay did you celebrate it it
was given to you but for what purpose to
honor
you did you were businesses closed on on
Heroes day many yes were schools closed
yes why the day is given to the school
you have a day off the business is you
can close but not to talk about you to
honor whom the heroes the Sabbath was
made for man that man May on the Sabbath
do what honor the Creator made for man
does not mean it is man's personal
possession the Bible repeatedly says the
Sabbath is God's
day but entrust it to us that on that
day we will make him the center of our
lives without distraction from work or
school or whatever else yes the Sabbath
was made for man not man for the Sabbath
on that day we spay special attention we
pay special attention to our Savior our
creator without the burden of work and
any other secular distraction all right
next question in keeping by the way okay
go ahead go
ahead in keeping the Sabbath should our
cattle not go for grazing with the
Herdman and added to that no no just one
at a time in keeping the Sabbath should
we do what should our cattle not go for
grazing with them oh yes the cattle
should go on graze do you have sabb
lunch well your cattle should have
Sabbath lunch
too the Sabbath isn't intended to make
us cruel and
harsh your cattle your animals need to
feed you're not breaking the Sabbath by
giving them water and food they need to
eat Jesus said if your animal Falls in a
pit on the Sabbath take it
out it's lawful to do good it's not
lawful to work it's law to do good
please feed your cows on the serath now
don't go above and beyond and work but
make sure they have what they need so
you need minimal effort to make sure
they're taken care of you can't let
animals suffer because you in church
singing loudly no no no make sure your
animals are fed and taken care of
because God made animals and he made
them to have fellowship with us the
Bible are you're told to treat animals
nicely there's a verse that says if
you're walking down the street you see a
bird's nest put it back in the tree with
a little bird that put it back in the
tree love animals take care of them Ela
tells us in Patriarchs and Prophets
those Before the Flood they love to kill
animals and that love for killing
animals LED them to disregard love for
human life because all life is from God
and the physical life as an animal is
like the physical life in a human being
next question or the next part of that
question well on that question the um
grazing with the Herdman your worker mhm
can they go with the worker the well
that depends on how you arrange that the
work The Herder should not work on
Sabbath but the animals must be taken
care of I have to leave that remember to
figure that out I can't give the details
all I can say is the animals cannot be
left to suffer on the Sabbath but with
God's help the owner can find somewhere
to so manage his stock that he does not
end up working or having someone work
for him there's always a way to honor
God when he wants obedience always a
way is buying on Sabbath a sin yes
yes and selling mhm mhm next
question no business on
Sabbath what if I stay home and keep
Sabbath and honor God what's the point
of joining church and being baptized
where I find people with problems and
bad attitudes and characters but you
have problems and bad attitudes
too huh come join the family are you
following me a family of bad attitudes
and problems we all need Jesus are you
following me didn't I tell you Jesus
said have I not chosen you 12 one of you
is a devil come to church now let's go
to uh Leviticus 23 a lot of people think
I can stay home and worship God you're
wrong not if you can come to church
you're wrong I speak with respect but I
want to speak clearly you're dead wrong
Leviticus 23 let's understand something
about the
Sabbath let me pray again father as I
continue tell me what to tell your
beautiful people that you may be
glorified in their lives in Jesus name I
pray amen you have Leviticus
23 and the Lord speaking to Moses saying
Speak unto the children of Israel and
say unto them concerning the Feast of
the Lord which he Pro sober be vigilant
because your adversary the devil as a
roaring lion walketh about seeking whom
he may devour now when predators are
hunting they're looking for four kinds
of pray the
old the
sick the Young
or the injured I think one of those
three if you watch any clip of cheetah
hunting or a lion they will identify an
animal in the herd and they will run
past other animals to get to that one
because they identified a weakness the
devil like a roaring lion walketh about
looking for isolated
Christians because if you think you're
all right by yourself you are wrong the
Bible says forsaken not the assembling
of yourselves as the manner of some is
especially as you see the day coming and
that day is the day of atonement we're
in that day now and on the day of
atonement let's go to Revelation chapter
3 Revelation chapter
3 let's read
verse
17 are you there Revelation 3:17 what
does that
say because thou sayest I am rich and
accre with goods and have need of
nothing spiritually Rich am rich
increase with goods and have need of
nothing and knowest not that thou art
wretched miserable poor blind and naked
someone who considers himself
spiritually rich and that wealth is not
Christ himself is blind to his true
condition it is dangerous and this is
the description of God's Church in the
end time that's us the leoan church I'm
rich in cre with Goods I have need of
nothing the church press me I ought to
preach but people would tell me you
ought to preach or you ought to teach
they constantly told me that so one way
is to listen to members of the church
who have observed you another way your
parents because they know you another
way is to take a test
the church has several spiritual gifts
tests or you may take an aptitude test
which also identifies if it's a good
test what your strengths are you can do
those things and of course number one
you ask
God God is a God who loves to talk ask
God as you make an effort to find out
for yourself don't ask God and fold your
arms ask him as you make concentrated
efforts to find out and the Lord will
guide you but as you do that don't be
idle whatever you're doing do your best
so when the gift is identified you will
come to that gift with a habit of
excellent
work but everyone has a gift because
that's how the church is built up
everyone has a gift and it's sad when a
person never uncovers that
gift all right next
question why is anointing oil not used
by our elders and pastors who says it's
not
used who said that I don't me don't
identify yourself but you're not present
at every Church how do you know
anointing all is not used I've seen it
used all over the place the Bible
doesn't tell us how often to use it it
just says it's one way to deal with the
sick anointing Mark chapter 6 verse
verse 13 they went out and anointed many
that were with with oil many that were
sick and healed them James uh
54-16 anoint with oil and the prayer of
faith shall save the sick so anointing
with all is biblically required but the
Bible doesn't tell you how often to do
it do it that's up to the person who
requests it or the leaders of the church
who notice it needs to be done but I've
seen it
done I have done
it all right next question the teaching
Aid of a picture or image used for Jesus
Christ holding a lamp in his hand does
it amount to idol worship no no it's a
pictorial representation we learn by
touching we learn by seeing we learn by
hearing it's not idol worship at all
when the Israelites were bitten by
snakes God told Moses build a broen a
bro a Brazen serpent put it on a stick
and he told him look at it it was visual
but think of Christ that thing
represented Christ because Christ took
our sins to deliver us and so no having
a picture or an animal picture something
to teach children no children learn very
well visually that's not
idolatry since we are saved by grace
does that mean entry into heaven is
automatic it's
automatic how do you say no in
Africans yeah that one M it is it is
absolutely not
automatic it is a daily walk with God
now if probation closes and you he that
is righteous let him be righteous still
ah okay but until that happens it's a
daily walk with God entrance into the
Heavenly kingdom is not automatic
because you can leave Christ if you
leave him there's no hope of entering
God's kingdom no matter the fact that
some Churches teach once saved always
saved so you get saved then you go to
the wh house the casino the gambling Den
whatever that's not the way the Bible
teaches you have to walk with God that's
why Jesus said abide in me Jesus said
Matthew 2413 he that abideth unto the
end he that endureth unto the end you've
got to hang in
there with Christ as long as you're in
Christ Christ you're guaranteed you step
out of Christ you lose that guarantee
but the guarantee is Christ not
you you don't automatically go to heaven
because you got once you could give your
life to Christ it must be a continual
renewal continual
renewal next question can Satan cast
himself out
no absolutely not nor does he have any
desire to do that no he
doesn't Christ cast him out he doesn't
cast himself out Satan gets into you and
wants to stay keep you captive he
doesn't cast himself
out
now the devil is so
tricky he may cast out one of his
people to make you think working through
some false prophet he may cast out one
of his people but how many demons were
in the gatherin demoniac Legion at
minimum 2,000 he could cast out one the
1,000 whatever 999 left so the devil is
not in the business of casting out his
people completely and entirely but he
may trick you no no no only Christ
casted out the devil and his
cohorts is the 144,000 in Revelation
symbolic or literal the church has no
fixed position some Bible scholars say
literal some say
symbolic either one has
benefits if you say symbolic and you
focus on the character not so much the
number or if you say it's literal you
can refer to the fact that at the flood
only eight people were saved when Sodom
was destroyed one righteous man came out
when Christ went back to Heaven a few
disciples in an upper room so God has
always had a few and so 144,000 out of 7
or 8 billion we have seen evidences of
very few following God so either way but
the church has no fixed official
position on 144,000
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't
study it MH the Bible says drink a
little bit of wine is it wrong to drink
wine yes well drop the word wine alcohol
perhaps a better word because the wine
the the word for wine in the Bible can
be fermented or not it depends on the
the the the context in which you're
reading now God can't say one thing in
one book and say something in another
book go to Proverbs Chapter 20 God does
not speak out of both corners of his
mouth as people say
Proverbs 20 let's read verse
one you have Proverbs chapter 20 verse
1 what does that say wine is a mocker
strong drink is Raging whosoever is
deceived thereby is not wise now in that
verse wine is condemned is that clear
then what did Jesus
turn from water in John Chapter 2 at the
wedding what did he make with the
water what do you mean by wine grape
juice because it was Jesus speaking
through Solomon who said wine is a
marker strong drink is
Raging in John Chapter 2 he turned water
into the word wine there means the grape
the fruit of the Vine grape
juice not alcohol that numbs the
senses you want to take a little wine
take a little grape
juice and ser and preserve your neurons
even a little alcohol affects your
judgment you what I said even a little
alcohol affects your judgment and
damages the fine nerves that you have in
your brain and the brain is no organ to
damage
deliberately next question
please share your vegetarian diet with
us because sometimes we lack such
information what do you mean you lack
such
information a vegetarian diet is a diet
that does not include meat as a practice
when God made Adam and Eve in Genesis
1:29 he said behold I've given you every
herb bearing seed which is upon the face
of all the Earth and every tree into
which is the fruit of a tree yielding
seed to you it shall be for me and to
every beast of the earth and to every
fowl of the air and to everything that
creep upon the Earth wherein there is
life I have given every green herb for
meat God's Arrangement was every living
thing should eat uh plants every living
thing ELO white writes I don't remember
where God allowed the race to eat meat
to shorten their
lives because God does not like Sinners
living long
God allowed that long lived race right
to eat flesh to shorten their
lives every time you bite into a chicken
leg you
are shortening your
life are you with me
mhm the purpose of meat arranged by God
is to kill
you sooner than you ought to die M so
it's not to spread sin all over the
place people say but Jesus had fish how
often did he have
it how many times can you point to
Christ eating fish or lobsters or crabs
or snakes whatever how often let me tell
you something else now for those of you
who say Christ had meat Christ did not
live in the antitypical day of
atonement since 1840 October 22 8 44 we
are in the literal day of atonement
spiritually now in this typical during
the Jewish era no animal products were
brought into the most holy
place are you with me no meat was
brought into the most holy Place meat
was brought into the holy place during
the other days and the priest would
consume meat in there as a way of
identifying with a
sinner no meat was ever brought into the
most holy place we are now in the most
holy Place phase of Christ
Ministry when Christ was on the earth he
was not in that phase so you and I are
living in a different historical ERA
with respect to prophecy and in that era
no meat was brought into the most holy
Place young brother said amen and he got
no support from
anybody now I'm not telling you don't
eat meat I'm going to be telling you
what the authori say the Bible and our
commentator sister white what she
writes she said meat lies at the
foundation of almost all the cancers
that people
suffer meat flesh
food is the is the cause of so much of
the cancers from which people
suffer I'm not telling you what to eat
I'm just telling you what the spiritual
authorities tell us by the way the
purpose of diet is to keep us fit to do
God's
work that's the fundamental purpose of
diet to keep us fit to do God's
work sickly people can't serve God as
well as they ought so God gave us a diet
to keep us fit not necessarily to live
long but to live well and to be active
in God's
service all right let's get to the next
question because I keep seeing all these
guilty faces
get the next question all right what's
the next question is it okay for SDA
singing groups to charge money during CD
launches book a Sunday church venue and
pay for that booking why
not why not there are different ways to
work some people work at Checkers some
people work at the bank some work at the
gas station some work selling
CDs don't sell them on Sabbath
you publish a book you sell
it why can't I publish my CD it's a form
of work Paul made tents and he sold
them if your profession is producing
music that's your profession but don't
work on
Sabbath and don't overcharge people
because you're a Christian business
person don't produce rap
music or rock music or whatever else you
produce in the media all right right and
the Sunday church venue H the Sunday
church venue the what to book a Sunday
church venue for the concert let's say
book a a Sunday church venue for the
concert I don't have a definitive word
on that but a building is a
building don't we rent our buildings to
Sunday
churches yes we
do it's a common well it perhaps not in
theia it's a common practice United
States we rent our churches to Sunday
churches it's a common practice we rent
Sunday churches to have our
services
mhm we
do so I'm not telling you what to I'm
simply saying Adventists rent from
Sunday
churches some Sunday churches rent from
Adventists there was a the president of
my conference the Lake Region conference
he used to Pastor
an Adventist Church that rented from a
Sunday
church then the Sunday church lost its
pastor and what happened they asked him
now he was pastoring two churches one
met on Sunday one met on
Saturday but as always ask God what
would you have me to do always ask God
your highest Authority Psalm 32:8 I will
instruct thee and teach thee in the way
which Thou shalt go Psalm 25:4 show me
thy way oh Lord teach me thy paths
always ask
God did Jesus go to the house of Sinners
to have dinner yes but he didn't go to
participate in the sins he went to
present himself as as a source of light
and life but he went to the house of
Sinners next question does the time of
having Lord's Supper be only during the
dinner time the Lord the Bible doesn't
tell us when in the day to have the
Lord's Supper nor how often it simply
says as often as he eat this bread and
drink my blood ye to show the Lost death
till he come 1 Corinthians 11:26 the
time of day is not stressed but we tend
to do it once a quarter during the
midday service on Sabbath but if you
read Acts 20 Acts 2 verse uh 242 to 47
they were breaking bread daily those new
converts I guess they were very excited
they were breaking bed from house to
house daily always together for that
person who said I can worship by myself
yourself next question is it okay for a
Christian to have a cash loan and should
it be tithed to tithe is based on your
increase if you given something you
didn't have before you have
increased and God says I want
some because all of it belongs to me and
if I want I can take
it we tithe
increase recognizing God is the rightful
owner of everything and then we leave it
to God to bless us you cannot give God
too
much so any increase you have
acknowledge God and watch God bless your
life as a business owner
something when I was a little boy here's
how we were taught about tithe which is
based on
increase if someone gave you a shirt for
Christmas we were told evaluate the the
the price of the shirt and return a
tith because a shirt is increasing if
the government assesses your wealth do
they only look at Cash do they look at
precious metals do they look at land how
many houses do you have do you have a
boat a plane a submarine they look at
everything you have to determine your
wealth back then in the Old Testament
way back people didn't have
cash they brought their farm products
I was in a certain country preaching and
this person came to me with a smart
question I am a farmer how do I return a
tithe I said you have a piece of land
yes cut it up into 10
pieces whatever grows in this piece
committed to God that goes to God sell
it in the market give the money to the
church I tell them you'll be surprised
that more fruit or products grow in that
little square than in all the other
nine MH always consider God
because everything is his and he can
take
it but God is so good he made seven days
he kept
one somebody say amen for a good
God God made uh all the trees he kept
one and told Adam leave it
alone God says for 100 uh I almost said
Pula $100 million doll give me 10
come on God is a nice person now could
God have said give me 90 and you live on
10 but he doesn't God could have said
give me six days do everything in one
God could have told Adam all the trees
are
mine that one alone is yours but that's
not the way God functions God makes it
possible for us to obey
him next question
H oh okay next question
as a business owner is the amount after
paying employees and bills what one
should tithe how should tithing be done
in general you
tithe your increase your profit let's
say you have a business your profit is
$500 you type that you see God must get
his first not your employees God must
get his first not the government now the
government takes theirs ahead of time
because the government doesn't trust you
to give it or trust me so they take it
out and then people say Let me give
tithe on what's left wrong you give
tithe on a gross not the net if God were
to love us on the net he would have sent
an angel to die not Jesus are you
following me and that would not have
worked God loves us on the gross we must
return on the
gross mhm always find ways to give not
find ways to take
back was TI the temporal
Arrangement well it's Arrangement until
the new world but it's an active
Arrangement right now you can trace it
all the way back when Abraham came from
the battle in Genesis
14 the Bible says he gave tithe to
melkisedek where did Abraham get that
habit from someone taught it to him
tithe goes all the way the concept of
tithe something reserved for God may be
traced back to the tree of the knowledge
of Good and Evil God reserved that for
me don't touch it don't mess with it
this is mine the concept of tithe being
exclusive for God that tree was
exclusive for him don't play with it
stay away from
it God's tithe must not be
used to deal with emergencies the tithe
is Holy do not touch it turn it into the
storehouse the Church of God let God
demonstrate his power to take care of
you next question what is the symbolic
principle of tithe in the Adventist
Church tithe simply says you acknowledge
God as the rightful owner of everything
and you acknowledge the fact that God is
trying to take selfishness out of your
life by requiring that you give him a
certain portion of your income the
purpose is to cure us of selfishness
that's the way we are
naturally God doesn't need money what
you do with money but he wants to purify
us of selfishness and greed so give me a
tithe support the work think of other
people
mhm part of what was revealed to John in
Revelation was the souls crying under
the altar yet the same Bible says the
dead know nothing please help clear the
misconception in addition God told Cain
that the blood of his brother Abel cries
to him from the ground sometimes Bible
writers apply human characteristics to
non-human objects let's go to Psalm
114 Psalm 114
you have
that when Israel came out of Egypt the
house of Jacob from a people of strange
language Judah was his sanctuary and
Israel his Dominion Now read the next
verse the sea saw it and fled now does
the sea
run what is the writer referring to the
part of the Red Sea he says the sea saw
it and
fled giving human characteristics to a
non-human thing keep reading Jordan was
driven back because 40 years later they
crossed Jordan so when they when he
parted the Red Sea the sea fled when he
crossed Jordan Jordan was driven back
the mountains skip like Rams and the
little Hills like Lambs now the writer
talks to the Sea what ill thee o thou
seed that thou fled thou Jordan thou was
driven back ye mountains that you skip
like Rams and you little Hills like
Lambs he is giving personality to
non-living things it is a style of
writing go to Psalm
98 Psalm
988 let's read the next to the last
verse what does that say of Psalm 98 the
next to the last verse verse what does
that
say let the what floods clap their hand
now wait a minute have you ever seen a
flood with a hand no the writer is
simply giving human characteristics to
try to express a thought let the floods
clap their hands let the hills be joyful
together before the Lord well how do
Hills do that and so when the blood of
Abel cries out it simply means that a
murder has been committed and something
has to be done eventually to avenge that
murder murder the souls under the altar
the martyrs who were killed The Dead
Know Nothing their blood has to be
Avenged we're using symbolic language to
make a point that's all it
is
okay we're
finished I have to go to another Q&A
right after this very shortly
after let me take this m to thank the
pastor for the joy of fellowshipping
with his church family I really enjoyed
it my dear
pastor and you've made so easy for me to
do what I came to do so easy so easy and
I thank you for that and may the Lord
bless you eternally bless your family
protect your children bless your
ministry may the Lord lead you as he led
Moses to guide his church forward Upward
at all times and may God grant you an
abundant entrance into his kingdom and
he comes thank you so much for the easy
way it is for me to have worked with you
I thank you for coming every night to
listen to God's word I really do I'll
miss you terribly when I'm gone but I
believe the Lord will bring me back
sooner than you suspect it may be some
other part of Namibia but Namibia
nonetheless I'm very grateful for my
little brothers who sat in the front
night after night I always look forward
to seeing you but for all of you who
came to listen to God's word a preacher
will preach to one person if necessary
but he prefers to preach to more than
one so thank you for coming every
night my counsel to you as your
brother make time for
this there is so much chaos in the world
people don't know what to make of what's
going on but a church of Prophecy should
understand what's happening when Pharaoh
had a dream two dreams he saw five good
uh seven ears of corn that were good
seven that were thin the good consumed
the thin he saw uh seven or the thin
cons consumed the good then he saw seven
fat cattle seven thin same thing God was
trying to tell him seven years of plenty
are coming followed by seven years of
famine Pharaoh couldn't understand the
dream he called All The
Magicians all the susers the the
traditional healers they could not
explain the only person who could
explain was Joseph A Child of God an Old
Testament Adventist can you say
Nebuchadnezzar had a dream D neb Daniel
chapter 2 he could not even remember the
dream far less what it meant he called
All The Magicians astrologers
Sorcerers and calans and they came and
stood before the king the king said unto
them I have dreamed a dream and my
spirit was troubled to know the dream
Daniel 2:3 then spake the calans to the
king in syak oh King live forever tell
thy servants the dream and we will shoot
the interpret ition the king said unto
the calans the thing is gone from me
you've got to tell me what I dreamt and
then tell me what it meant they couldn't
do it he threatened to kill all of them
but Daniel was counted as a wise man you
see so he would have died but Daniel
Prayed with his
companions and God gave him the meaning
the only person to explain political
events to Nebuchadnezzar was a child of
God Daniel an Old Testament Adventist
now
the only people on the face of the earth
now to give an intelligent assessment of
what is going on is the people of
Prophecy not CNN not MSNBC not your NBC
where I spoke a few days ago the people
of God who understand Last Day Events
and what's
coming but you've got to study this or
you will surely be deceived
this will preserve your
children this will strengthen your home
this will broaden your mind to
understand your school
work this will protect you from harm and
danger that's why Jesus says live by
every word and so I commend to you the
word of God to bless every area of your
life if there's someone in the church
who's hurt you forgive the person if
there's someone you've hurt
apologize coming to church well dressed
looks nice visually but very often it
conceals all the sores and the warts and
the infections that lie under the nice
clothes because people don't get along
with people they have long-standing
grudges that have never been
resolved but we smile every Sabbath fix
those things and let the spirit of God
move thank you again so much God bless
you I love you and if we don't meet on
this side as people usually say but I
hope we do let's meet in the new world
can you say Amen because that world is
coming until then wherever you are if I
come across your mind all I want you to
say is Lord come on put your words in
that man's mouth shall I take your love
back to my wife yes or no say yes okay
I'll tell her you treated me nicely I'll
oh let me thank Those Who provided food
ah God bless you God bless you but a man
is far from home he's not sure what he's
going to eat know sometimes people bring
you dishes and you have to say grace
twice because you're not sure what's in
front of
you one's for thank you for the food the
other one is for protection but I thank
God for the good food the ladies have
given me gentlemen don't be angry but
let me talk to the ladies thank you
wherever you are thank you and may God
bless you and may your oil and flour
never run out
because you've taken care of this least
of God's disciples and apostles I really
mean that God bless you eternally little
boys and little girls Jesus loves you
and he wants you to give your life to
him he wants you to live for him and if
you do that your little friends will see
Jesus in you and they'll come to Christ
instead of your friends turning you to
Mischief you can bring them to Jesus by
you being faithful his word and obedient
to Mom and Dad thanks again let me offer
a prayer for you can I do that
Pastor head bow I
closed dear father in
Heaven you know more than anyone how
delighted I have been with my time in
this part of the world father you know
how every night i' go to my window look
over the land and thank you for the joy
of being in the
midia I thank you for the people your
Sabbath keeping people in specifically
and all others
generally I ask you to bless the
Adventist Church in theia Father wrap
your arms around them preserve them from
harm and danger keep them from error let
them live so Faithfully that the church
in this country will literally be a
light that shines brighter and
brighter bless the government direct
their deliberations dear
God bless our online audience that came
night after night bless the countries
they represent father in all that we do
Keep Us Faithful I pray save us when you
come in Jesus name let God's people say
amen and amen God bless you
[Music]